and then his bio says not a prince just
the frog
you ain't getting no dates you're not
getting anything from here
hello and welcome back to big mood we
have a lot of people in the house we're
missing gina cause she's getting new
boobies but we do have a nikki blades
which we are very thankful for
and i'm thankful to be here thank you
what was that about another cube
that was cute she did not finish her
sentence at all she said nicu
thank you uh we all we also have some
other people on this side of the couch
who do we have i don't know who is this
casper who is accompanied by tiffany
that's casper might be introduced for
now i'm introducing people like i've
been here long enough to be like and you
are
so lovely to have you here nickname what
do you want to be i don't know
first off i wasn't calling you casper as
i know i was saying in between
i thought you were calling her casper
yeah
there are no boys on this set that is
how you see yourself
is that how you see her because i was
like oh you were
playing i'll just go with it i was like
you're the guest you know
i'm gonna go with it i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna call your whole life people
have called me casper
[Laughter]
whatever i actually have a slight tan on
today actually
sure and you do yes you do yes you do
yeah don't be talking too much you ain't
that much darker than she is
she'll get real dark i get real dark
okay
anyways what are we talking about this
uh what are we talking we're talking
about people's dating profiles
yeah yeah we did an episode where we
went over
things that guys hate about girls
profiles and things that girls hate
about guys profiles
and then at the end we asked you to
submit your dating profiles if you
wanted us to review that episode was a
few weeks ago go look for i think it's
called dating profile no no
yes something like that something like
that so i'm coming in with
new eyes yeah and just kind of fresh
eyes brush eyes no bias feel free to
call them like really absurd nicknames
you know based off what you see
please disclaimer do not come at me
they're telling me to do this i'm so
sorry in advance this is why i'm here
okay i think we're gonna we're gonna
keep most of these so we got this
mcgee over here yeah so so good good
hello what an exciting
place to roast them too hard because i
wish i had big tits
okay yeah i thought that's what you're
calling nikki
oh yeah yeah i love to be referred
to by my first name which is that it's
the key
nikki i am part irish so you are close
there you go
you know what this is fun yeah i'm
having fun we are gonna
review our first profile now okay this
is from what's her nickname
uh cutie pie 17.
cutie pie 17. that's a fake made-up name
because we're keeping her real name
anonymous
yeah hip-hop hip-hop anonymous
um okay so the first picture it says hi
here are the screenshots of one of my
dating profiles
so she sent us like three screenshots
four
four there's four okay first off this is
super cute
very pretty i wonder if this is i wish i
knew which one that was the main
profile usually it's probably the first
one that's what she did
it matches her instagram it says oh yeah
yeah can you guess my usual order at in
and out
she cute she looked like she get a
protein style
no french fries unless she's being wild
animal style at the the top it says
first round
is on me if you can guess my usual order
at in and out yeah that's a usual hint
like a prompt
okay so very cali girl i'm getting san
jose vibes
very much protein style but she probably
has a very specific
in and out order let's scroll through
the photos strawberry milkshake
what do we think about the photos like
what how is this presentation
she does secret menu um
she gave me listen i like escape rooms
we're trying
we're trying to rate her dating profile
i'm like trying to figure out the rating
right
okay so so how do you think her photos
are
okay first let me see the photos first
yeah
all of them it's the first one and then
the second one it's like a friend or a
sister maybe
oh really it's oh that was the same
person yeah yeah it's so
what before and after oh is it like it's
like hair up hair down or like a year
later
oh okay yeah i thought it was like a
twin or something
and then this is okay okay look a little
full by what's the
prompt on that one to open it up a life
goal of mine oh okay a life goal of mine
is the prompt and then she says
to open an avocado toast cafe my avocado
toasts are life-changing and totally
worth the 15
i plan to charge do i have alcohol
because i'm gonna need a drink after
that
did she just say her life dream was to
open up an
avocado okay we're getting young we're
reading yeah
that's that's fine yeah i don't care she
must be over 20
because i'm gonna need alcohol at this
point
she's 28. we got no excuses here's a
really good avocado toast place that has
bottomless mimosas
and i will tell you i will go out of my
way to go to there's a place downtown i
think
that's pretty good in l.a i forgot what
it's called it's a big-ass
big-ass restaurant breakfast kind of a
vegan place and they have pretty good
avocado
i would just say based off the photos
she looks fun
like i'm looking at her photos and i'm
like i want to go out with you i want to
grab a drink with you
i don't necessarily i just want to like
hang out i feel like sundays are
awesome with her and saturdays she looks
like so much fun but i will say the
first thing i notice is boobs and i
don't know if that was oh
yeah if that was planned like if you
were really like
because the boobs are front and center
look at the yeah how many every how many
cleavage shots
yeah maybe because i got tetas myself
and i know how hard they are hide the
hard to hide
but i didn't okay look at this photo i'm
getting in the car i'm a real
girl look at me i'm trying to be candid
maybe a little natural and also you
you show off your best assets so i'm not
like really hating on that no i don't
feel like they're out because i
do well and i know after photos the
black t-shirt photo yeah that one
they're not
see and that's what the beauty of this
is is because we're all picking up on
different vibes
i did not notice her boobs at all i
think for me if i'm
trying to to embody a man right now i'm
just saying
oh cute avocado toast oh cute here's
titties so i'm thinking
i want to take this girl out for a good
i definitely want to bang this girl like
yeah it's hot as [ __ ]
but i'm not getting buttoned up
librarian vibes no
right but that's not what and that's not
necessarily what you have to do
right but i'm just saying i do if she's
getting a lot of guys
attention i do see a lot of cleavage
it's like cutesy cleavage yeah i see
sexual attention i know what
sexual attention looks like being like a
hyper sexual
female well there's also like i feel
like it's a spectrum too yeah and be
extremely like in bikini
so for me i'm catching like she's fun
like she's definitely
she's definitely fun she's putting her
flirty foot forward right i would say
that
yeah flirty foot i'm showing a little
bit more yes crop top
and young i'm getting very young i would
have said 28. she said 28 i would have
picked up on 23. yeah
i'm pulling 22-23 yeah 22. 22
23 something fun very light
i feel as though she's not looking for
anything serious at the moment
yeah yeah yeah cause i didn't get
hypersexual let me tell you i'll pull
you up some accounts where i'm like that
girl
well not hype first not hyper is hyper
sexual but like
hey i'm here for a good time okay yeah
you're gonna have a good time
remember spectrum because for me i'm
like
she fun like she's smiling a lot she's
giving me very
light you're gonna have to take me to a
restaurant but then like i know how to
have a good time not like i'm gonna
she's not like i'm easy or anything but
like like i
am very i'm a guy probably
dtf is what i'm doing i don't know that
but that's just and for me maybe
regional area i'm picking up very much
like
day party fun time she's going out she
looks like she's in college she's
probably
like when i say san jose because i'm
getting young i'm getting that energy
the i still enjoy going out i would love
to bring her around my friends
she looks like she can handle herself
around the guys
and she looks like a girlfriend she
looks like plenty of the girlfriends
that i've seen
with guys that i know and when she's
smiling so much
it gives me a very positive energy smile
too yeah yeah
really great smile great face and i like
you can see her personality come out
with
prompts like a random fact i know is
goats have accents that's really cute
like that's really yeah
that's like what else do you know yeah
so i'm getting like with the prompts and
the photos i'm getting like
not super worried about something
serious right away yeah
obviously she probably wants a boyfriend
but like not like
yeah i'm putting it out there that i'm
here for marriage and i'm
like my titties are hidden behind a
button-up shirt like her intentions are
different to more to have fun she's a
sunday brunch girl she looks like she's
brunching so i don't know
uh miss what did we call her cutie pie
cutie pie i don't know that's your
intensity reading what did you say
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me sorry excuse me but cutie pie
number one you're absolutely beautiful
you're like a [ __ ]
ten perfect face perfect teeth beautiful
body
you look really fun like good job girl
yeah you got it going on yeah i would
definitely hit you up if i was on the
dating app
yeah if it was me i would definitely
hate these are my expectations
oh yeah we're going out and if you like
me like yeah
you're fun yeah yeah in other places as
well look i will tell you this from my
perspective
i would actually probably bring you
around my homies
yeah i look at her like you know what
you might be able to hang with the crew
if i'm looking for somebody that's still
like we're still going out we're still
having fun yeah she looks like she's
down to have a good time like she's down
for everything like to play
pool or yeah like go bowling or denim
shorts and your
dating profile lets me know that you are
down for fun yeah
down to fun down down to fun all right
we love her thank you first of all what
are we going to raise for submitting
because we did say we wait how are we
going to rate them i don't know how to
really
i'm just rating based on whether or not
i would hit you up if i say yes
i never know if like if is the picture
going right or is it
overthinking it don't overthink it
it's my finger you're swiping left to
say no because like you tell like
beyonce i said put your box
to the left get out don't overthink yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah we got it but yeah
i'm never going to be on dating yes
okay you're married it's okay i think
she was very balanced and showing her
personality and looks
yeah i will say though i think if she
had hobbies
that she was interested in i would like
to see more pictures of the hobbies yeah
you played tennis let me see you need a
little cute
tennis skirt with your tennis racket or
what are you like because they're all
just more about her i want to see a
picture of them
yes oh yeah are you [ __ ] chucking
down some avocado toast that's a very
let's check out a dude's profile all
right profile number two
thank you for submitting um let's see
big boy 69
sure yeah big boy 69 we have a
male here um uh he says he's gay
so we're gonna look from like still a
male perspective
yeah yeah okay yeah pretty much so he's
24.
i do really like this opening shot even
though i can't see his face i'm
intrigued enough to want to swipe and
see
this thing i want to know where he is
yeah where where is this because it
looks beautiful
giving me cultured vibes yeah yeah okay
yeah he's also dressed nice
yes well not for traveling because i
know like when you're traveling you're
supposed to like look nicer
and i feel like really it's like kind of
the cut jeans and stuff i don't know if
that's
that's nice i don't know i guess i mean
are you trying to go to europe
yeah because europe you have to look
like in a suit right
i mean where is this i don't know yeah
uh based off of where he says he lives
i'm actually impressed by his attire
yeah he looks nice though i'm not saying
he doesn't look nice at all he looks
nice
yeah is there another he also this shot
is like um from the ground going up so
it gives a
very aura of power very
interesting men always do the shots from
below because yeah like gives them the
power pose
and when you always do it from above to
look thinner right look smaller could be
five seven looking cool six two he does
look tall yeah that is a that is good
okay let's see what is probably i also
appreciate how he's actually looking at
the camera i noticed a lot of people
that were submitting profiles that guys
in particular they were not looking at
the camera like they would be like
side angle or i don't know it's kind of
weird i will say i mean i know that you
said right away
oh no i like when it's like a head shot
as the profile true
so i can like see you in detail because
that's his face was pretty far away
yeah yeah okay we just went to the next
slide
and it is a photo of this man going geez
oh he is 24. what is that
right what's he doing
oh i'm so old that i don't even know
what the [ __ ] that is i only know
because of my 13 year old he keeps me
he keeps me young ice in your veins
what's that yeah
you cool it was started by a basketball
player um that he would do it
after he you know scored himself yeah so
is that
like it's a young i'm i mean for your
dating profile
oh yeah yeah so me seeing that right
there i'm like
24 year old probably gonna date down in
age so maybe you would have 20 years ago
it doesn't maybe that's not all most
girls date older guys no but like
oh no he's like yeah he's gay yeah so
like there's a lot of that
yeah age difference yeah um but you're
definitely showing your generation by
doing
that picture like that yeah but maybe
other people i don't feel like he picked
this one in particular because he looks
really buff
yeah there you go yeah he's working out
he already put that in his profile too
like he likes working out he likes the
outdoors he's a foodie if you're doing
this ironically
oh he's a bartender i'm sorry i didn't
see i didn't see the description but
okay
it's the last photo he's like i guess
he's like a party guy
like whether or not that you think
that's cringy or not like if he likes
tick tock and he likes that stuff and he
needs to find someone that likes it too
yeah true so he can't not be himself you
know i'm just saying it's separating you
into a category right right
well we are oh we're separating
ourselves you're cutting off a
generation yeah
yeah well unless they don't know what
that means so they wouldn't matter
anyway
if he gets a granddaddy you know like a
silver fox that i don't even know what
that is yeah oh wait hold on
then we talk about didn't we talk about
gina told us
with that with that band
so okay gina said that the band tattoo
around your arm means that how that's
how far you fist into someone's [ __ ]
but i don't think that that's what this
is
maybe in certain circles that's why i'm
like he is a gay man like i don't know
that's like he did not go past this he's
like killed someone
oh yeah he killed someone and that's how
far that's like on the farm
yeah okay let's go to the next um
picture can we get some paragraph or
something well the paragraph's the last
one
okay let's see i just want to hear a
little bit yeah all right
i am a 24 year old bartender server oh
okay
bleep that out because it's where he
lives my interests include but i'm not
limited to
coffee fitness outdoor activities hiking
paddle boarding swimming camping
shopping watching man mainly
horror movies or horror films with
someone
food in all caps possibly the least
picky eater
and going to the occasional rave looking
for
a pilot to fly me out to texas so when
my dad moves i could go see
her first off you got zaddy you're
looking for a zaddy right in your
profile did you tell it
she said looking for a pilot to fly me
out to texas very specific
okay i mean i do think pilots deserve to
he likes maluma
so he likes maluma his music tastes good
he's fun bartender norcal
he's full of [ __ ] he's lying so there's
people that are into like slow drip
coffee and like the the intelligentsia
okay okay he's not old enough
to for for a sophisticated hobby is the
worst i don't know when i was 24
hipsters were really in so like being a
hipster was super in everyone was into
like slow drip
everything and look he's looking for his
daddy i don't know let's just cut to the
chase 24 year olds are different now
this is a 24 year old man looking to get
flown out let's stop playing
because i want to see his face a little
bit more so okay oh
i like this photo a lot it shows a lot
of his personality yeah
if i had money his sweet family stuff
yeah if i had money
and a plane i'd fly you too yeah
[Music]
he's looking for his target audience
yeah he's doing quite well
yeah yeah that's really cute yeah he's
showing like his range
he can be the fun like sheesh guy and
then also like look i love my family and
it's like a teddy bear yeah
i like the rain i travel it's like a
range of a personality exactly yeah
and then him with uh maybe his that's
probably sisters or something
or girl friends i'm okay with that on a
gay man's profile but
if he was trying to be [ __ ] pissed
by these [ __ ] especially because he
cut the face out
out of the other girl yeah so if it was
a straight dude i'm like was that your
ex-girlfriend
yeah i see where he's going i'm fine
yeah
oh more travel okay all right
um well before we continue talking about
style if you are
wanting some stylish clothes to wear in
your profile picture and you don't have
a clue where to start you should start
with stitch fix
stitch fix is an online personal styling
service
where you actually have a stylist
picking out
clothes for you based on the interests
that you tell them you have
on like after you take a quiz so you go
online you take a quiz basically it
shows you pictures of clothes and you
say whether or not you like them and
then a stylist can like
customize your personal style and curate
a box for you
you try on pieces at home before you buy
you keep what you love return what you
don't stitch fix has free shipping easy
returns and exchanges
and a prepaid return envelope is
included there's no subscription
required
so you could try stitch fix once or you
can set up automatic deliveries
you pay just a 20 styling fee for each
box which gets credited towards the
pieces you keep so if you keep
something that's over twenty dollars
boom that twenty dollars gets discounted
from that
that piece um and there are no hidden
fees ever stitch fix has styles and
clothing to fit any occasion for women
men
and kids they ship all over the u.s and
available in the uk
as well oh all right mate get started
today with
touchfix.com mood and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com
mood for 25 off when you keep everything
in your fix
citrix.com mood yes and really quickly
i'd like to also shout out raycon i love
when rayquan sent us
uh the earbuds yes i was like i'm not so
sure about these i'm not so sure
but i've been using a judgmental [ __ ]
because i don't know i used to be
in a cult with another brand and i would
never be willing to try any switch over
yeah but then when i got these and i
tried them the battery life is
in safe and they're really good i can do
all of my chores all day i can go to the
gym
i can do work stuff after that with my
earbuds in and they don't die as fast
which i absolutely love the sound
quality is great
and the the price is so much better than
a lot of other brands
whether you're jamming out to your
favorite music or catching up on your
favorite podcast like this one
a pair of raycon wireless earbuds in
your ears can make all the difference
you get crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium audio brands
they look great and feel even better you
guys know what i love is that they're
smaller and rounder and they fit into
your ear so when you take your
shirt on and off
listen up raycon is offering 15 off all
their products for our listeners and
here's what you got to do to get it go
to buy
raycon dot com slash big mood there
you'll get fifteen percent off your
entire recon order and it's such a good
deal
you might wanna grab a pair and a spare
that's fifteen percent off at
byraycon.com big mood
by raycon dot com slash big mood no
seriously it's a great deal for the
quality of what you're getting they
really
are but back to the car dude big big boy
big daddy what'd you call him big boy
16.69 yeah so this photo is just
i don't know i feel like it shows like
city city
trying to i'm trying to be like that
stoic ness stoic he's still smiling in
it
i think it shows like a city a city vibe
what is that even the self painting
of the photo yeah what is that a cell
phone i think it's a train
i think it's like look we'll go on an
adventure we'll go on an adventure
around my city go hiking
i guess okay side profile i like the
nail polish in this one
oh yeah he's giving good serious he's
showing quite a range
he looks like he's probably on his way
to work he has a shift he's
getting a good face good manicure
that's a nice photo it's clean it's a
nice photo you're gonna tell me this guy
doesn't like slow drip coffee shut up
you know what after that i mean then you
see this one that's not he's
yeah he's like really goofy these are
really shocking he looks like he dry
shoots pre-workout he does
don't do that no dry scoop it's in a
garage even
yeah yeah okay so overall
big boy 69 has shown a range he can be
emo
he can be jockey tick-tock um sir you
look like you're on a date in this photo
oh it does it does look like you're on
it yeah i don't know what he's trying to
convey here
i wear my mask the one with yeah he's
sitting outside
he's sitting outside on a patio at a
table he's got a mask on you can't see
his face you really can't see anything
so i'm not sure why he chose this
yeah i would wouldn't use this picture
yeah um it doesn't detract from the
profile for me but it's kind of a waste
of space
yeah exactly when you can use that slot
he's got so many other good ones i don't
think he even needs like you could just
take that out and it'd be totally fine
yeah yeah it's well-rounded without it
um would you guys swipe right
on yeah nine i would oh totally
good range good range i don't know what
gay men are looking for
but as a woman the range of things
interests
yeah there's like a lot of interest in
hobbies there it seems like a lot to
talk about just based off the pictures
i mean but i do love he was pretty
straight to the point do you want to fly
him out
honestly if i was in the position he
looks like he would be good
yeah right texas i said texas
twice texas and nobody noticed
so it's our third profile we uh nikki
blaze here requested a
hot girl because she is a hot woman i am
bi
yes so she can give a so i feel like i'd
give a genuine
yeah uh review to see if this is
somebody that i actually wouldn't want
to go
with yeah okay and what's her name
i say this is rainbow girl 72
rainbow girls 72 yeah there's a lot of
rainbow girls rainbow bright
rainbow bright rainbow bright okay all
right
so she's 25 okay she's a gamer or like
under her interest is gamer karaoke
musician
grab a drink tattoos in her bio it says
show me you can belt it out in karaoke
and i'll have the utmost respect for you
will absolutely destroy you and tekken
if you're into that
winky or wait upside down smiley face i
won't start mowing your lawn at 7am on a
saturday but no promises
okay side note she knows who
she is talking to she knows her audience
this is a very specific
person these are a certain type of
people the karaoke
the tekken i love tekken i hate karaoke
because i can't sing
but i get her humor she is looking she
likes the confidence she
is looking for a certain type of person
and honestly if you are not her cup of
tea
i feel as though she does not care yeah
i love it i love it look what do you
think about this being a
video sorry to be for to be ignorant
it's a second is a
fighting fighter fight like mortal
kombat almost oh yeah yeah it's kind of
old
but this photo i want to ask you all as
this being the first photo
are you all cool with that no i wouldn't
select this photo as the first photo i'm
swiping
i mean i hate to say it i'm swiping i'm
not i'm not
okay so what do as a bi woman what
makes you not want to swipe off for me
personally the main focus looks like
the dog and just an emphasis on her hair
and i know where she's going with it i'm
getting very game revived
stream revives that energy yes for me
personally
that would not be the strongest photo
she could have went with
i think that her personality is way
brighter than her dog
and this feels like i'm looking at a dog
and her bio doesn't say anything about a
pet lover so it's almost like why is the
dog here
yeah well what about it just being like
kind of sexual in the water like that
i get no sex abuse i get
no sex because she's not really showing
that much of her body in the water like
if if her ass was bare or like she's
wearing a thong and then you're touching
the water then my eyes go there but
my eyes do go to the dog and here it's
also kind of hard to see what the rest
of the photo is too
because she could be like giving an
expression that we don't even know
exactly like that might be drawn i think
yeah
well let's check out some other photos
yeah okay all right next photo
kawaii kawaii yeah yeah love
she's cute i really like that one um oh
this one's nice she has cute
lighting my favorite one so far that
should be your main this i would have
not made that her mane just because i
feel like she's going for us
she is going forward yeah but that's a
stunning photo she's absolutely grateful
absolutely beautiful this is like this
is what i can look like without my
colorful hair
yeah well oh it's the hair yeah i i
didn't even notice so i guess
i i am sub consciously yeah you're going
for bias
yeah i'm biased against the rainbow
bright hair but like
she just looks so beautiful like this
with the natural hair i was like oh this
is the picture that should be on front
but if that's
if she's not going for that based off of
her bio i know where she's going you
know like who she wants
yeah who she is type of personality
exactly
and i love that so this is a beautiful
photo yeah i like that photo a lot
i'm like her mom i'm like i'm the one
without the women
i was like go pick that one you look
like you're you know you just started
your career
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
now we're like kind of cyberpunk so dope
a young
she's hot i mean this is a hot this to
me is probably one of them like
i know where she's getting at this is a
great photo do you think this should be
the front photo
i don't think so yet because i still
haven't seen the rest but that's a good
photo to have
okay this one and this one needs to be
completely get rid of it
yeah it doesn't go along with the rest
of no her perspective
show anything was she showcasing i don't
know you put that on your story when you
bought new shoes
yeah it's kind of like oh i'm being a
little bit cheeky sexy because my
shoulder is showing yeah but you can't
even cause it it blends in with this
yeah going on
yeah it says girls on tinder will say
quote your parents will love me but your
neighbors won't
like what are you gonna do start mowing
at 7 a.m on a saturday
i don't get the meme you don't get it
it's like the parents will love her
because they think she's a sweetheart
but the neighbors won't because they
know she's a freak in the bed
yeah i mean she's screaming but then
she's like well i don't get it
[Music]
for me throwing that joke in now it's
kind of like well i'm
i'm the [ __ ] type yeah yeah no like i
i'm can't promise i won't yeah
if you want to put that foot forward
then that's okay that's your prerogative
but if you're getting a lot of guys that
just want sex that could be like that's
kind of what you're doing well you're
putting those eyes in the eye emojis
the you know the eyeball emojis give it
away that that's a sexual innuendo
is this tinder because i don't know
david i i have no idea what
no this is i think hinge oh is this it
is that you can get verified on your
wage
wait what is this one i don't know i
recognize it maybe this is tender
i think so for me looking like looking
at her page i didn't get the like i'm
dtf that's not what i necessarily got i
caught the vibe
well even with the eyes like the eyes
going
and then the sexual media yo let me tell
you i know i'm a very
hyper sexual girl i know what my images
look like i know what i'm portraying and
i know what to let you know that i am
down
for me this is like a subculture i'm
catching a lot of this definitely a lot
of subcultural a lot of the vibes and
i just think she's fun and she's very
much in that lane but she is not a shy
girl
she is down for a good time absolutely
it sounds like she's not looking for
anything serious it doesn't
yeah not this is not a relationship the
quote
the eyes those things i wouldn't
necessarily go she's only down
to just smash no i mean that but i'm
just saying like i
there's a lot of things that leave me if
i was a guy i'd be like oh she's dtf
oh okay those are the signals i'm
getting for me but that's not
necessarily a bad thing if totally
that's what she's going for like there's
nothing wrong with that
no she's hitting a real specific group
of people
yeah and that's blatantly clear if you
are not into this you swipe right away
yeah
that's she's looking for somebody in
particular that's it she's going to be
swiping
she's swiping yeah she's swiping she
knows if you didn't get the tekken
reference like you don't have you don't
stand a chance
damn i don't stand a chance yeah yeah
yeah you're out of the running pattern
that purple hair was cute and all but i
really love when your hair was naturally
would you yeah that's me and tiff are
the moments like only like the third one
with the brown hair
um i would definitely swipe on her
because i'm friends with gina so i feel
like i'd get a gina experience
yeah so um yeah i would enjoy her right
i mean just want to change her first
picture change the first picture yeah
which one would she would she change it
to then from out of all the i like the
camera
one the pinball the cafe you like
the one yeah i like i mean that shows
well the pinball one's cool one is so
cool if i that if that first popped up
i'd be like yeah
actually yeah it gives the whole vibe
yeah her whole like it's like in a
nutshell it's like i'm a gamer i like
karaoke
i i will beat you in tekken yeah she's
securing herself
i would pass honestly but i think that
that's more
preference than preferences preference
not personal yeah
oh personalized i guess because i don't
actually have a dick i'm like oh i want
to be your friends i'll still swipe
right for me
like i don't have a dick and i probably
like do i want to sit on your face or
not
yes i don't necessarily think that's
what i'm going for
yeah for me it's like i'm not rating
based off of whether or not i would
swipe but more off of like the here's
the vibe though
audience swipe yeah the audience would
definitely swipe yeah whoever she's
going for if they are that person
you're going forward you will reach your
target just change that profile to that
girl you make that that's a bad
[ __ ] photo it is it really is yeah for
people on audio
sorry that like you got to watch the
picture on youtube
yeah there's a she's in a school girl
outfit but there's like um
a kinky leather course corset underneath
and then she's
leaning up against a pinball table so i
would say if you're into anime or into
any type of
uh things along those lines if you have
seen food war
i'm getting very much competition with
the blazer
pleated skirt and buckle bra purple hair
knee-high boots killing it next to a
pinball as her mom i would love her
to like look like the third photo
um but we can wait till she's 30. she
can do this at 25.
yeah go away she can grow out of that
later next she's gonna look i mean look
how beautiful she is
stunning stunning you do you sound like
a mom
i am an old ass but i'm almost 10 years
older than her so maybe that's why
that's true oh yeah profile number four
we got a dude
uh tiff what is it what is the message
so he wrote to us he said
hey girls i've been watching you since
you first started and i feel like
you really inspire me i've learned so
much about women which being gay i have
no use for half of the thing
oh all the gays are profile we need to
strengthen
next okay i recently joined tinder so
here you have my profile
to add some variety also i'm from spain
so i translated the text
oh that's nice of him all right so let's
look at a photo first
which which one do you think is this
probably he screenshotted the first one
first
yeah would that be it hello
what are we calling him what are we
calling him wreck-it ralph wreck-it
ralph
so wreck-it ralph he's 27 and he
mentioned he's gay and from spain
and this is the first profile i don't
really love this first photo
he looks like he's bored yeah or is he
laying up against the wall or the sheets
yeah
or a bed i thought it was like a mural
behind him
but yeah it makes more soccer ball bed
sheet is what i i read
honeycomb powder i'm not completely mad
at it
his face looks good i feel like he
probably
i see the board but i understand where
he's going also his skin looks
perfect i don't know if he is that a
fill filter yeah yeah maybe
and he's like his skin is like way too
good yeah
i think overly filtered photos are
something that we talked about
well this isn't overly because it's not
cloudy it's not cloudy obviously
it's not obvious but it's just like
here's what i want people to consider
when you use a filter like this when
they meet you in real life
is your skin even gonna come close to
that like you know
i think it should look at least still
have like that some texture
in it okay in your picture i appreciate
personal opinion
well it's besides that like overall just
a photo to me
he's just like laying on his back he's
got his hand on his stomach a little bit
and he looks bored
and i'm like well i don't want to hang
out with you because you look bored yeah
even though you're probably a really
great guy and really fun to be around
don't let that be the first impression i
have to use that you're bored
i want to read the text all right so he
translates
text it says oh it's in purple yeah it
says software developer
and then the next purple it says height
and weight parentheses i don't know
everyone does it
and then his instagram handle and then
at the bottom it says looking for a
serious
relationship or friendship no hookups
i'm a chill guy
rather stay home than go out to party i
like video games
tv shows and movies amateur baker slash
cook
looking for someone patient and with a
good heart
that can help me a little push so i can
stop the overthinking and just
jump and then under interest it says
baking
gamer movies escape room board games
okay he got me a nicky like escape
and can help me like with my what did he
say
it sounds like it's trauma from his past
relationship yeah
it's a little too much on the like i
haven't even met you yet and already
know that you're gonna need like mental
health
help and i'm like maybe that should be
taken care of
before you're dating yeah but not not
necessarily that you're gonna have to be
perfect before you can find a
relationship but if that's still
so much on the forefront of your mind
that that's your first sentence and
you're not going to attract people that
will actually help you in a healthy way
you're going to attract people that want
to manipulate you or take advantage of
you they know that
you've got that you're going to need
them you're going to rely on them
so you're going to attract narcissists
part of me appreciates that and i'm like
oh
okay maybe you'll weed out but i think
you said it right there it's going to
bring in a certain type of person that's
going to see that and take advantage of
it yeah so
and honestly your display picture does
not the first picture is not
the good description not
or yeah the personality i would just say
the
emotion in the face yeah emotion in the
face so get rid of that video game
sure what let's see cookie photos yeah
all right i think the thing is like
people want to see photos of you doing
the things that you say that you're into
because you like that kind of show it's
like a visual representation of like oh
if we went out
like this he's smiling here
can somebody please explain to me why
gay men put women in their photos maybe
it's the show that he
they like they all have the fruit flies
you know they're always there
is that what it's called i don't know
fruit flies
i don't know but they used to call it i
mean we have pictures of girls in our
photos too
i mean it feels like this dating profile
first off i am putting no other women on
a dating
profile you ain't seen nobody else but
me i
know that that's like a common thing to
like display like to show that you have
friendships like a life outside of a
relationship
and i'm clearly crazy so don't take
advice from me
ain't no other [ __ ] gonna be on my
phone you can blur their face though
yeah
now that looks like you're crazy no it
doesn't it kind of
does okay yeah it kind of looks like
don't look at her now
photo on a dating app and i've had
almost all the guys that i do talk to
said
thank you for letting me know which one
you are by like blurring the face or put
little smiley faces over the other faces
i can see how it can be taken either way
okay so just questions they just need to
know who you are
photo i don't have a dating profile yeah
i've never made it i don't have one now
either okay
so the purpose of adding a group photo
with other women is to show that you
have friends
yes well it's just like life because if
all of your photos are just you it's
like well are you a narcissist you only
think about yourself
hobbies you have you know like it's just
what you want around like pictures
i have no hobbies yes your whole life
you know what i'm saying it's like look
these are my girls like because these
are my interests these are my friends
this is my life
but then the blur of the face here's my
dog the emoji over the faces is not like
don't look at them it's like you need to
figure out who you're looking for
like in this group this is who you're
looking for good insider information
because that would have been like first
off i guess i would just
cut them out but you want to show that
you're trying to show the group
and i think that's what they're doing
here too like profiles
yeah he has girls in the photos so other
people like me
i'm okay with the girls and the gays
yeah and the photos but if it's a guy a
straight man with a bunch of girls
photos i'm like
instant swipe left yeah but he looks
super fun because he's like a teddy bear
we see your personality a little bit
more more of a teddy bear yeah
i would clean it up i think he needs to
he needs to clean up the hair and the
beard a little bit but that's what he
looks like i know but if i don't know
just for me personally like
preference preferentially i would clean
up the beard in the hair
a little bit it would make him look
super young though
maybe he's going for a little bit more
of a mature vibe do we have more photos
yeah i mean
oh here's look he looks more clean-cut
he looks better clean cuz completely
different
no you don't think so you don't think he
looks better in this photo
[Music]
i think he does but i mean that's just
preference yeah yeah okay yeah
i think so too because it's like even in
the previous photos it was like it was a
little
dark well because i like them a little
riff sometimes okay
i like it i like the variety his eyes he
looks so handsome
like he's giving me who is this okay
this is the same
person this is fun this is way more fun
i feel like maybe not the first photo
because you might get the wrong idea and
be like who's this [ __ ] weirdo
but like a second or third photo you
start to see the sense of humor you're
like yeah okay
he looks funny because he's out of the
last photo he's at a dinner table and
he's given a little
a little smirk a little funny wink kind
of photo like playful
i'm playful i'll kick your i'll rub your
foot under the table you know yeah
yeah look he low-key look like a
different person you got to be careful
with some of these angles because i did
not know who that was until he looks
like the same guy to me there was three
different versions of the same man
so but i know who i'm expecting to look
yeah to see what i think the first one
we
we don't get any sense of your
personality yeah i hate the first one
there's just
so many different ranges and you can
tell that they're taken so far apart i'm
just gonna throw that out there
somebody who's looking at the same
photos these look like different time
periods well like it's also different
five years apart
different completely different angles
like the first one it's like it's like
right like straight on
the second one it's like from underneath
so is the third one right
and then the third one's like at an
angle too and then yeah it's just like
the
last i felt like he gave you a little
bit of range yeah
definitely but jess likes the more
cleaned up version you know
hair done everything and one thing that
i think helps a lot with hair is
function of beauty
yeah functional beauty has been
sponsoring us since the beginning
and i i have not used any other shampoo
or conditioner since it is literally the
best
yeah i stopped using the other one i was
using for a while switch over
it just like it customizes completely to
what your specific hair type is
what your specific hair goals are and
i've just never had a shampoo or
conditioner just
nail it and like hit it over the head
and it lasts forever
you know i just said like i recently not
recently switched over it's been a while
now but i still haven't finished my
first bottle like the first set
yeah like six months six months
it's it's nuts and also the smells are
so good i guess okay so you go online
and you fill out a quiz that's how they
know how to customize it but there's
like a
trillion different combinations and
formulas that they can come up with
based on the answers that you give every
product is sulfate and paraben free
vegan cruelty free and there are over 60
000
real five-star customer reviews so you
know it's good
i'm like 50 of those functional beauty
fans are absolutely wild about the
fragrances and for good reason your hair
has never smelled so amazing my hair
smells like peach right now i know
it's mine you know they have a mango
sent out right now oh this is the one i
ordered
yeah i ordered it i just got the mango
one i haven't smelled it yet i'm excited
gripped your hair yeah they have crisp
pear also
or subtler scent such as lavender rose
and eucalyptus i got my body
my body wash and my lotion to be pear oh
my body washing lotion is rose
yeah it's it all smells really good
eucalyptus is great
um well jess go to functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
on your first order
that applies to their full range of
customized hair skin and body products
all of them are amazing by the way
that's functionalbeauty.com big mood to
let them know you heard about it here
and to get 20
off of your order function of beauty.com
big mood yeah while your hair is
smelling nice why not have your teeth
look amazing
too with candid you get to straighten
your teeth from the comfort of your own
home
so candid are the clear comfortable
removable and practically invisible
aligners to help straighten
your teeth and now like a lot of people
have
used this service and they absolutely
love their smile
so it's pretty cool how like i said you
don't have to leave your home
you end up having your treatment
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement
and you'll have the same quality of care
that you'd get from an in-office
orthodontist
but from the comfort and convenience of
your own home and while other companies
use
general dentists candid only works with
orthodontist
with candid the same orthodontist who
created your plan is there with you from
the start
to the finish so you'll never have to
wonder how you're doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months and you'll start seeing results
way before then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
become your best you start straightening
your teeth today right now you can save
75 on candid starter kits go to
candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's candid
co.com mood code mood
take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75
on your starter kit candid co.com
mood code mood yes okay so wrapping it
up for
this guy wreck-it ralph bro
he knows his cuties i'd like you to take
one more picture as your profile picture
that kind of shows your get rid
personality
some emotion yeah just get rid of that
first one because
i think you're losing out on a lot of
people that
haven't gotten to see all the rest of
your photos because i swiped on the
first one yeah and also there's no full
body shots
i think all pro profiles need a full
body shot because i have no idea what to
expect from the chest down
yeah yeah um but i would i think he
looks like a teddy bear i
i mean he's a gay man so i'm not in his
market
i think he does he just needs to figure
out the photos a little bit more but
he's
he i really like that one i like when he
looks cleaned up
the the cleaned up one where he's he's a
little got the closer shape yeah yeah
that's
almost good in that profile and i do
like the one at the table
i like the one at the table
yeah i agree too cable good luck you
need to get a straight man on here
yeah i do want to see a straight man
that's the only person
type that we haven't covered oh my lord
let's
do that one yes
is well actually i don't we don't know
okay we don't know it doesn't
specify if you straight i think we'll
figure it out yeah
so what are we calling this one this guy
is mad max mad max okay yeah i'm mad max
because of the first photo his eyebrows
are their little
prophets yeah dexter oh his message his
name is dexter
i like dexter so do we we're breaking
back he's like breaking bad
dexter all of those combined i vote
dexter what are we going to do
so he wrote what's up big mood my name
is bleep
from bleep here are a few screenshots of
my tinder profile it's
it's basic as of now but i'm willing to
hear some insight to improve oh i like
that
i don't include that i've been a stage
actor for six years and that i do improv
comedy should i
better for a later conversation
absolutely you should
why don't you that would explain the
photo
that's interesting yeah that helps it
helps me understand why this
yes first photo is so strong this is a
straw i mean i would swipe left on this
immediately
because it's giving me murderer vibes so
i agree but if it said improv comedian
you're like oh different type of person
or it just needs to be a few downs
you down the slide he is giving me
breaking bad off top wait what is this
what let's read this because his bio it
says that he's
28 years old under his interest his
astrology art gamer museum comedy okay
but this and then his bio
says not a prince just a frog
you ain't getting no dates you're not
he's probably making a joke to like
you're self-deprecating
don't do that honestly it comes off bad
on a dating profile because
you're we're actually looking for a
prince so yeah so you're telling me
you're a [ __ ]
dud you're subconsciously starting to
put your message out there or at least
bring up the comedy you have to throw
that in somewhere because
as we're reading that we all just wrote
them off i don't know for sure
yeah even if he's hotter than me i don't
even want to give him a chance because
i'm like oh
yeah you're not here for the long time
i'm not going to kiss that one no the
rest of the bio says i like acrylic
paint on cheap canvases
and then a whole bunch of astrology
signs okay i don't want to know that
sunshine has raised his rising and his
moon instant swipe left for me
he can and then he writes i can speak
english obviously
spanish and japanese aspiring to be a a
member of team rocket
stop it okay so the cards pokemon right
yeah okay
so so the references it's like the avi
it's very he's what he's being cheeky
what's the word like he's being what is
satirical
what is the word that i'm like ironic
sarcastic
very sarcastic i'm getting three other
photos [ __ ] vibes from
i would i would keep reading if i saw
this he wants advice on how to improve
this so we'll yeah we'll give him some
minutes
these photo combinations are throwing me
off here i don't like when guys look so
serious
third one is a lot better than the first
one at least better no you're like
attractive and an [ __ ] so this gives
you i might kiss you and then pass you
on
it's more [ __ ] boy vibes for sure i mean
it is look wow
okay okay photo ted bundy yo
who is this man he's going to murder us
taking you home that's why he likes the
zodiac signs
oh [ __ ]
killer because he's an attractive man
right but he's the type of attractive
man that's got the shark eyes and he
scares me yeah looks like the eyebrows
it's the eyebrows it is the eyebrows
sir you are terrible why is everyone
doing this
i want to be ugly 1970s thing now i have
those glasses
but you look you look better you're
welcome no you look better than him than
he does right here
if i oh see i'm confused
this is a paparazzi photo he looks
candid
it's the um setting
you do military time is 1700 hours
but y'all don't know what time that is
but i know that you're better
you better see that on the dating
profile that's his personal screen but i
know
i know you're a military don't conflict
military time too i was like why do you
do that he's just like i don't know i
just do
you get used to it like when i lived in
mexico they always use military
all right just anyway that's irrelevant
these photo combinations
and threw my vagina through a loop i am
comfortable is there any more photos
because i don't
i don't know if these side profiles it
says uh
anonymously please okay click on it
again i want to know the moon
i want to know the astrology okay so we
got gemini virgo
i don't know the last one it's crazy
psycho he's [ __ ] nuts
do you not see all the personalities he
just showed you in like four slides
he literally got two different frames
for seeing
and he got all these different faces you
gonna wake up with a cereal
he got a cowboy hat did he look like he
cooked coke
and then he got the other one he's a
cocaine cowboy and then
then that's who he's selling it so he
needs it who's buying it
you don't want nobody to eat a frog so
you pass but that's
cold it's code for like i got the drugs
yeah yeah
this [ __ ] is a setup oh [ __ ] personally
i think he's an attractive man
and i think he needs to figure out who
he is and what he's going for
because it's just it's as a girl that
wants to be
taken seriously i'm definitely swiping
left and maybe that's okay with him
like maybe he's not i can't think of the
market that he's looking for
america he's trying there's no there's
no girl that i've met a girl
with no personality baby okay look at
her
the latina and like okay let's get the
lenses from the
because i have a feeling he's mexican
yeah he's definitely hispanic yeah yeah
hispanic blood for sure yeah and so like
i feel like what he's giving off here is
like
machismo stuff yeah yeah he's he's
really like
tough but he can also have fun like with
the vaquero hat yeah
and but it's mainly like i'll be your
protector
kind of thing protector i feel like he's
he looks like a
predator i feel like that's his vibe
though i feel like that's why he's
trying to protect it from music
but also i feel like he's also very
insecure about taking photos
that's what i'm reading yeah that's why
he has to come off like so let me
[ __ ] throw this away
he looks like he gave away all his
aliases like
oh look if you ever try to commit a
crime sir we know what you
like in every this is
bad you gained too much range like give
us
less like babies
look give me that last one i want to
know if this guy has
hot no pictures with
okay i'm gonna tell you this probably in
person i'm getting
real like he's giving me sexy vibes like
there's a couple like that photo
yeah i'm getting fun i'm definitely want
to go out not that one we've been going
out with him
this guy now this guy right here yeah
we are going out the hoodie we are
getting the dream when he makes out
he lives all
[Music]
the brows are disney villains the other
one yes yes i'm like
hey and you're but if you're a frog you
can't do anything about that
well no he looks good there but if
you're a frog
he's just saying use me yeah
the next one that photo make that your
display pick boo and you're good delete
that's right
please remove the one with you got no
facial hair in those glasses yeah he
does he
that makes it
and the expressions may are what the
disney villain eyebrows are not the
actual eyebrows because like that
oh this is a difference in low light
stopped take it away now we even got
good
i've seen so many of like my mexican
friends like in my space days
like this these are what it is 2021. i
know but i'm saying like that's just
like how they they take he looks like
he's looking at my titties in a zoom
call
i mean but he's in california so we
ain't giving him the mexico excuse this
is not a different country you are
2021 in california where he is
21 year old self would definitely go for
this because he reminds me of one of my
exes
even the no beard maybe not oh this
one's nice when they shave yeah
he looks like yeah he looks like
hispanics shaved cleaned up
you know but like they look like all of
my exes that's why i'm getting triggered
by it i think
he ain't turned on
that's what's given the different
personalities
all the different faces yeah that's true
see that is cute i'm dating you i'm
making the bottom one the bottom one is
the least you're my boyfriend
the bottom one is the least scary and
you look like you're playing poker at a
table
and i'm like we're doing something fun
for you
i would date you i'm sleeping with the
other one and i'm dating this one
yeah so advice you heard we need to
we need to get it
if your market is murder victims then
you're killing it right now
yeah i don't know i i think we need some
different i mean he should include the
stage actor for six years and that he
does improv comedies
i don't like his paragraph right now i
think he needs to include more about
himself
likes you know start over this is the
bio right now i don't like anything
about the bio
at all i mean i guess he's trying to eat
look at him you speak japanese that's a
little cute you should put a little
sushi emoji in there
i mean also i like to eat so you know
that's cute yeah i mean a very
attractive dude i just think he needs
better
photos that aren't so creepy like
way too attractive to be creeping me out
this much yeah
keep your beard don't shave it off all
right so would we swipe
left or right on this connection the
current state i would swipe left
exactly yeah i would have to swipe left
on him it's a very nice
market that you're playing for right now
i don't know a whole lot of people that
would swipe right on
and it's current state but you got some
ground to start
with yeah yeah you just need to just um
photo three take out the murdery ones
yes and adjust that bio to be more
personal
first line and burn yeah yeah i just
it's too much
bimbo and then like [ __ ] and then
like it's just
it's it's not it's coming across heavily
and he's so
handsome that i don't get why it's such
a [ __ ] hot mess
like there's not this it's a hot mess
like don't
yeah but we like the last photo because
we like i like that photo
we like the one the straight the
straight on one the straight on and the
lights
the golden hoodie you see how it's got
more warmth in the photo
it's less like you're already dead kind
of again
he looks like his bio that photo looks
like the bio and then if you delete it
you
upload the last one and you look like
you're a boyfriend yeah
yeah he would do better without
boyfriend that's a boyfriend
yeah i'm taking you home yeah
non-threatening like it all right
guys well there's actually a ton of
other submissions there's a ton of other
submissions and you guys can continue
to submit if you like this episode if
you liked this episode let us know in
the comments we will continue to review
other people's profiles from time to
time
let you know you're asking for the
advice you know so we're
we're just this is not unsolicited we're
trying to help
based on our opinions this is only our
opinions uh
yeah and we're probably i think we're
older than every single person that's
submitted so
wait maybe we're not in your market but
yeah
totally roasted but that was fun i
really
enjoyed seeing everybody and you guys
are all attractive people yeah
really attractive listeners goddamn we
have an attractive audience
they're harder than me i'm getting
insecure through each other they're all
hot
to each other y'all sexy big mood dating
service yeah
yeah we need our own app hi welcome to
the big mood dating services
what's your mood what's your most mine
murder yeah i have the perfect person
for you
uh also be sure to check out nikki
street eats yes
no chasers nikki blaze 99.7 now big bay
mornings
subscribe to big mood and rate us five
stars and we'll see you next time
bye